while I was gonna say all here together
ever six I'll be serving Tamra I've gone
from wearing a fedora but if this is bad
no we can find bad things about today
yeah so cool
Joe we're not sorry going from this
screen now we're gonna be really really
boring darn it Jim yeah yeah are you
listening
get the death stare you dreamt about
yeah you sweet chewing gum in okay so
we're just gonna go ahead and put you in
here huh you noticed me oh he almost
killed the camera to avoid this camera
all the stuff of me talking to the
camera we're gonna do later or I'm gonna
do later um so I'm gonna have you what
that would please him
I need to be pleased oh okay you know
that was nasty
hell but he he takes the camera
and he's just like the camera just comes
around only the camera that I just
you're I need you
there's not a mattress in here office of
an apartment we don't shower those Oh
insert a million fans alive in a lab
write it even though he requests at the
time Phoebe I have the same voice okay
all right so first thing can be critic
yeah and then you're going to I have to
pronounce all of the punctuation marks
like dot dot comma critic dot dot yes
yes you do um so critic yeah and that's
when you're gonna be looked at the
camera and then if you say a critic yeah
that's when you look up and we'll see
you recording uh what are you doing
isn't it great I recruit the glory days
in my first review like you're missing
one of those important elements it's
only half a review without it it's okay
and I guess I can go to here it's it's
okay I thought about that like I hit the
sidebars out of the way get up and I go
to your site I've decided to fill the
void with other spin-off Craig's
including Beth Black Creek and they're
all gonna be this man's Mimi er yeah
like waving in the corner yes you know
it's good that we just don't use Malcolm
s I'm sort of twelve I don't never why
write this I get flack for things you
write both houses are given like that
wasn't me this is a parody Blues
Brothers 2000 so he's the black blues
brother he's the kid was driving um
let's see little kid critic sexy woman
critic
let's get an anime cat critic and
invisible critic that might just be the
wall and finally can be a critic it's
just gonna be Brandi she's gonna be like
it's a very we just put giving a white
t-shirt and some white makeup and hand
them just up against the wall just like
invisible car yeah well I just wanted to
show a wall oh that's good yeah I think
that we might use it for something by
the way you misspelled Malcolm oh really
at a scene and in and the corner dress
you are lying you've basically someone
is filled the entire way I don't know
that specificity that's a lot I want to
show he's lying that's how you spell
your name right let me see uh
actually that is how I spell it so hmm
you do not mmm the mag that you had to
prove in on camera she was so really far
gone you are okay I am good you know
your audience would have believed it I
am only saying I was likely have
incredibly subtle dyslexia so so mad
whenever I make a mistake everybody on
the internet notices so oh wow
okay hold still yes it only attacks when
it's the most inconvenient the most
people will notice Lexus if it's subtle
dyslexia it's like dyslexia with another
letter that's in the wrong place but
it's silent yes okay so okay so we're
just gonna go up to you know just suck
at spelling that ever occurred oh no
that can't be it that's a good point
someone's just bad at spelling they can
always just it has dyslexia
oh damn like many people have legitimate
dyslexia I think you're using that as a
crutch
I've never been tested for it but it's
like I'll read a sentence like three
times and still you won't talk about it
maybe you want we're gonna be dr. Phil
session right here sure oh are you
getting this ya don't want all of your
chickens in one egg before the half your
basket she snorted there really like
that so don't worry Annette dr.
Phil okay uh so I think I think we can
go to me naming off all the critics here
uh tell you what go ahead grab that look
over the lines while I frame this stuff
Oh terrific
no you got to like dr. Phil now oh all
right
what are you doing do you see what
you're doing you see what you well
you're missing one of the most important
elements it's only half a review without
it it does sound like dr. Phil you
sound like anymore yeah not
anybody just funny people just many of
you okay wait what funny
gosh chair
I do remember when I was playing Sam the
instructions said I was wearing yellow
oh yeah that's right y'all shirt
yeah this is a fan request or something
critic hockey enjoy recreation that has
half of who made a good forceful comedic
sidekicks practically nothing new to
offer no fan base that demanded to see
it in the first place is such a new line
okay good it's easy now right
Bubba cruder what are you doing isn't it
great
I'm recreating the very first episode of
nostalgia critic but you're missing one
of the most important elements it's only
half of you without it yeah this is long
I have a bit of there hasn't been food
let me scoot from that liner from the
beginning I live again but you're
missing one of the movements but you're
missing one of the most important
elements it's only half a review without
no no it's okay I'm taking care of it
you see I fill in the void by replacing
it with a bunch of other critics like
black Critic little kid critic can't
look it critic animated kitten critic
invisible critic though that might just
be a wall and of course cameo critic
that's mister miss tells you kitten
invisible critic who might just be a
wall and of course cameo critic he's a
delight it's a douchebag he's a
delightful douchebag you only review Z
grade corn yeah he's gonna see a
Flintstones why okay good oh do this
so it's a cookie right there yeah so am
i staring at you then yeah I think over
it yeah you're look at me I think your
body was more that way already like I'm
looking at me and then you can sort of
turn like critic
you can't just blah blah and okay I
think I was like this okay okay
recording Jane Rowland all right and
action
but critic how can anyone enjoy a
recreation that has half of what made a
good forceful comedic sidekicks
practically nothing new to offer and of
nofa na ha good long list yes this is
critic how could ya face face that face
lo ha ha ha that's like he's excited to
punch something pretty Jim Rohn ready
rob and see it at the door oh my eye
alright touch space so we come to the
Holocaust no wait we fight like that got
it Adam Sandler movies and there you go
yeah blended blend is little Mickey and
Sam were in a was it what's a player
where'd he go now uh Africa that's right
all right it bombed oh it's oh yeah oh
she shaft goes to have got my hamburgers
your favorite Adam Sandler's next belt
okay
critic
how can anyone to enjoy recreation then
that has only half of what made it good
forceful comedic sidekicks practically
aah
just like we lost Steve let's okay rim
your hand was over the whole line I'm
lucky I remember that the bunch what are
you talking about Craig okay right yes
how can anyone enjoy recreation that has
only half of what made a good forceful
comedic sidekicks practically nothing
new to offer and no fan base that
demanded to see it in the first I think
they get the idea okay
blues - mm good yeah I was getting a
little too tight okay yeah I mean you
can go like really really slow how I get
out yeah Creek
how can anyone enjoy a recreation that
only has half of what made it good
forceful comedic sidekicks practically
nothing new to offer and no fan base
that demanded to see it what so and I
think I get the idea okay
blues marries mm good all right and do
one more Australian more
how could anyone enjoy a recreation that
has nah half of what made it good
parable is okay yeah yeah cuz if there's
anyone I could say his own line so well
if you proved it to Posie flee it's like
what the hell did I write when I'm like
write all these novellas I still is able
to say get your 12 tastes
whoa brilliant take five on this one you
need to warm up how could anyone enjoy a
recreation that has half a vote made a
good forceful comedic side kids
practically nothing new to offer and a
fan base that never demanded to see it
in the first point I think they get the
idea
Oh blues berries mm good good that's it
one more you yeah okay do I have as many
you know quick
how can anyone enjoy our equation that
has only half of what made it good in
the first place
forceful comedic side kids practically
nothing new to offer and a fanbase that
never demanded to see it in the first
place I think they get the idea huh
whispers mm good okay I can do together
okay I was just thinking of blues roots
mm good really that food was oh yeah
yeah I think at one point when you were
talking you were served going like uh
you know yeah you looking at the script
but you're kind of going past my face
when talking so so be sure to keep the
head still but I'm moving in some but to
see I'm trying to do it in between the
lines so that looks like I'm trying to
think of what I'm saying and then bath
you okay no cares won't recent forceful
blah blah blah it just it looks like you
know script check yeah yeah yo idea was
like that the rest was really good cuz
you're still keeping the you know if a
they want me to see like right here
enough like that you try that okay
forceful come on I love it
okay okay ready mm-hmm
ready Jim one and action Creek how can
anyone enjoy a recreation that hell is a
refresh as half of a make it okay I'm
ready all right critic how can anyone
enjoy recreation that is half of what
made a good forceful comedic sidekicks
of practically nothing right right yeah
Creek how can anyone enjoy your equation
that has only half of what made it good
forceful comedic sidekicks
practically nothing new to offer and is
something that no fanbase demanded to
see in the first history yet more more
inner face that demanded to see it in
the first place I'd be less what
happened since Fargo left
I'm the new barber
maybe you whatever say it again no no no
no Douglas tell Devlin I am done this
Creek how can anyone enjoy recreation
that only has half of what made it good
forceful comedic sidekicks stop covering
this oh okay okay
I almost feel okay Creek how can anyone
enjoy a recreation only is half of what
me good forceful comedic sidekicks
practically nothing new to offer and
wasn't something that the fan base ever
demanded in the first place Saturday
they get the idea our Blues Brothers
2000 where I punch look real
I'm dad in the sound effect for that one
I'll be in my trailer
excuse me - what's yeah okay now it's
time for everybody to wear the suit -
yes
I get to be Manik never let him write
anything I remember when you're the
executor how many tight you're just like
oh yeah you're just like damn I write it
you know they tell that your own yes but
I know my own writing but I know yours
okay uh-oh uh-oh
it does realize you're the face you're
making ah yeah go ahead and stand up I
think we can do this I need you to take
a picture okay sure
while these days I'm gonna have you not
in a costume and you'll have
and you're going to be looking over this
way
just like you like the yeah the way my
guys are the kid wave okay don't put my
head there I have to put that back on my
head say suppose the young I'll see if
there's something classic oh yeah you
don't have the earrings right no the
other one she did the kid in a yeah it's
a pimping kid wave try one just go like
this good I say go ahead put down the
district and action just uh looking less
boyish one see me could try with your
eyes open while you do that okay ready
and action
it's something that someone made a
comment actually there like that boys
kind of busty well that one Rachel did
uh Emily and I see that's what the
reasons we gave her the boat cuz it just
me yeah that's clearly not a kid when
she turns to the side cool all right
oh we're gonna go you take picture music
oh yeah yeah oh yeah thank you hey and
that's the end of the bond crap sorry
we are so
so vo my baby Johnny right this Rob
perfectly when I turned this camera
actually then no I really was the end of
the boat okay I'll let it cool off some
more let it cool off somewhere I'll do
another reading for you yeah this is us
in front of the scenes because it's not
really behind the scene right where'd
you see you like fall on me so what's
the motivation for the scene pass out be
disgusting oh yeah yeah that would suck
if we need to do it I'll do it
hmm for the office for the alt yeah I
think what we'll do is that we'll have
we'll have a close-up of you falling
over with the foam and then we'll have
one uh the medium shell with the two of
you and Malcolm you feel like oh we go
we go to the one that's further round
with me talking to the camera I mean I
think we can just have like the phone
out there I think we'll be okay mhm so
yeah that should be good
lectures I gotta see the towel in there
pretty sure we won't smile like this
biggish
look I have for you yeah I don't think
any of us have had to do anything like
this yes I yeah I've never done a homing
one yeah I said no I think I send the
email like Jim if you can just find out
some way to do combing I'm like it
one would think it shouldn't be
complicated right who knows you know
this is an old gig the one the one that
I do know that works really well is like
baking soda and peroxide and vinegar
yeah yeah yeah listen I'm both yesterday
that one works really well tastes awful
yeah we can try this first if it looks
good it should look as good if it
doesn't if we if you wanted some to a
bit more expect a clear she's willing to
to try the vinegar
making soda dammit I do have to be in
this no I think we could actually do it
without you well we can keep you out of
it because it's pretty close on her so
what do I do
all right so just you're gonna take sip
of the water hold it your mouth kind of
just in there and I'm going to pour in
the and just kind of swish it around
once or twice and it's just gonna open
yeah so so so what you'll do is that you
know you do it
swish around and then you'll also have
the smile on just slowly like yeah like
that over
oh yeah that way yeah I know we wondered
a little bit like shaking no no you're
you're still just happy you're just
going down and just this bones that yeah
the more content you can look as you're
falling over the funnier it'll be I
think no not yet we have your book this
stuff that's just what happens when we
do water I take too much is like oh I
guess no I can just do it okay yeah
that's a little bit ready and fall
it looks so great and looks so great do
you know it's really great yeah you're
right I didn't seem to be that bad yeah
looks fantastic
okay anyway you got you there correct
Jim yeah okay so the next one will just
be the far other oh oh so that's a take
yeah yeah don't know I can't really in
one take
yeah it was right yeah let me double
check just to be sure but yet I think
you look pretty fine ya know that that
looks very funny hey I could hear you
crack it up there yeah yeah I was like
hey hey did you read Malcolm mm-hmm and
actually well sorry
keep it together came together Oh down
there Onassis oh sorry about that I was
just like oh no I lost it
what does foaming feel like I'm very
ticklish very tingly it was yes so I
don't think isn't be that immediate oh
yeah yeah it shocked me too I thought it
was just gonna take a while but was like
yeah I felt it was a very interesting
sensation it didn't taste very bad
though oh did you feel like a rabbit
Tamara I love it everyone's gonna think
we're doing Old Yeller
right do what
yeah no I'm Doug hmm that was great
yeah well yes well done Jim finding that
yeah I had always like she wanted to try
that I never both of those techniques I
knew about but I was like see how it
works right
it's good
that of your back pocket this makes me
wonder what other things you have in
your backpack yeah a lot of things out
like it I get a chance to try like stuff
all the time doing this to my guinea pig
yeah it's like perfect what else is in
the lab yeah cuz people ask all the time
about you know how you do all this stuff
and I'm like well just get more gym in
there yeah the gym show you need so J
Russ corner yeah that's actually a good
cheer us PCB right so I give them
MacGyver channel awesome so speaking of
how Jim whips things up what's about
what's this project about here um this
is uh one one day build its how to build
like a proper piece of equipment in a
day uh-huh cheap materials so yeah it's
how to turn a cheap Iron Man mask and to
a star-lord helmet and that is one
badass helmet just like stuff that you
find laying around right yeah it's stuff
you could find in a dollar store or
hardware store it's basically just a
mask a child's helmet and just some
plumber's putty and PVC tubing and stuff
it's amazing
see now everybody knows so my all my
tricks yeah well they they know of them
they don't know how to do it but now you
can with your channel right so yeah I'll
have to put a link in the video
well now link but uh like just show it
to them like go to that link people it's
cool
all right okay I'm just gonna be talking
to myself like who's that that's hyper
again she's everywhere exa money you
have like something we're like you
actually live in this like somewhere I'm
sorry it's like everybody goes home and
you like hide some great right exactly
and I look like a wardrobe villain right
just hiding below wait is the bum house
still around or yeah I just read that
was actually if one of the drugs videos
what if he destroys the boathouse oh wow
so yeah just comes out of the float that
was great like yeah we're saying that um
she actually never leaves the studio she
like lives here everyone goes on yeah
just lights go out you see here like
come come other girl yeah I got make
she's been living here yeah yeah Doug
Walker is here okay just listen hold on
look how Doug hey it's great to see you
yeah how'd you get in here looks like a
head of throw on a character who by okay
can't be here yeah no now the real
question is is they all gonna be a bit
wait if she wants to so defeated who's
Doug like yeah yes so the continuity
doesn't make any sense
well I think we've referenced a few day
like there was more I think failing for
us over like just saying he was saying
like you know yes you know I bet the
bomb would really like it with me and I
come in like
you should eat sir it's like and so are
the credit and that's like me as the
critic that's right it's like but wait
when the bomb Watchi CBGB outfit ah geez
I got her heat so cool oh do we want to
welcome to oh yeah yeah
commentary tag